outside the meeting room if the fire
alarm should sound please leave the
meeting room by following the fire exit
signs and meet on the Ipswich Town
Football Club trainer pitch do not
re-enter the building until you're told
it is safe to do so please switch off
all mobile phones or turn them to silent
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the Internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed by
entering this room you were also
consented consenting to being filmed by
the council and the possible use of
those images and sound recordings for
webcasting and/or training purposes the
council members of the public and the
press may record film or photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
finally camembert's and officers please
ensure the impress the microphone for
speaking and turn off when you're
finished can I move to the agenda please
agenda item 1 apologies for absence
thank you chair we have received
apologies so far for councillor called
thank you agenda item 2 declaration of
interest by councillors
the monitoring officer has gone to
dispensations to all members for the
item MC / 19 / 7 which is the draw
flicker plan are there any other
declarations sorry house revealed yes or
on the local play no I did discuss with
the monitoring officer the issue that I
am a trustee of a trust that has an
interesting and application in the Bible
area but as convinced that that is best
of personal interest there's no
financial implications for me and
particularly the issue is that the
societies within the Bible part of this
and I have already I believe approved
the plan so he was confident and I don't
have any issues that shouldn't cause me
to wear which are from the chamber or
any such take any satisfaction thank you
I'm sorry counselor Willem Thank You
chair just to say that I was a member of
the Stowe upland neighbourhood plan
working group thank you very much
item 3 MC / 19 / by to confirm the
minutes of the annual meeting held on
the 20th of May in 2019 for accuracy
only are there any issues with accuracy
could I have a proposal thank you can I
have a seconder
Thank You chair I'm happy to second
thank you
so we'll take a vote those four so those
four
thank you thank you that's scary
item number for the Chairman's
announcements I refer you to paper MC /
19 / 6 to be noted counselor Alton yes
it's a query I think I did email you and
count them only because I was a bit
surprised that there was nobody at the
presentation to chris fry somebody who
was leaving this council after 29 years
so I just wondered whether you had made
any alternative arrangements to wish him
well we I was on route from Cambridge at
the time and I rang him councilor
Phillips as joint ward member for need
to market and also the town mayor this
year I'd like to thank councilor Susan
Moore lenity for the donation of the
flagpole Thank You councillor Willem
Thank You chair can I just clarify under
the ledger contract working party that
the task and finish group will look at
ways of taking activities out into the
community I'm sorry you've moved on to
the next side seriously connect to clean
oh yeah sorry sorry so um item agenda
number five the leaders announcement I'd
like to invite Susan councilor Morley to
present her tabled update Thank You
chair wise leaders report and
any questions counselor well Mt wants to
get back to your point
thank you sorry I jumped up too soon
yeah it's to do with the letter contract
working party and when we met before as
a task and finish group we were looking
at ways of taking activities out into
the community particularly the rural
areas will this task and finish group
look at more than just the centers at
Stough marking struggle Cancer Center
would you like to answer thank you for
your question I think we need to take
that to the task and finish group that's
what we're going to be talking about and
we are going to obviously have
presentations from both both the
contract contracts the people who were
asking for the contracts okay so we'll
take it we'll take it all up at that
time counselor ebon would you like to
speak thank you very much chair could I
thank through you councillor Morley for
providing a written report leaders
report albeit a few minutes before the
meeting I hope that in the future that
we'll get a leaders report slightly more
in advance so that we fliest any queries
on it we can them raise those questions
in advance could I also ask whether will
be receiving portfolio holder reports on
a quarterly basis and thirdly I would
have hoped to attend the algae a
conference but unfortunately aren't able
to due to my illness so I hope to and
that those people attending will be able
to provide a full report to Council so
that we can all benefit from those
visits thinking counselor Morley would
you like to respond to that
yes portfolio holder reports will be
coming quarterly and yes we provide an
update to the a g8 conference and you
just need to bear in mind that the
sessions that I attend do may well be
different to the sessions that say John
or Gerrard attend - are there any other
questions right so we're moving onto
agenda item six to receive notifications
of the petitions in accordance with
council procedure rules Thank You chair
we have received a 47 valid signature
petition regarding planning application
DC 1901 five five eight in Corner magna
this will be dealt with through the
usual planning process thank you item
number seven questions by the public in
accordance with council procedure rules
Thank You chair Nam received rights and
number eight questions by councillors in
accordance with the council procedure
rules Thank You chair again none
received item number 9 MC 19-7 labor and
mid Suffolk draft local plan preferred
options before invite councillor burns
to introduce this report I would like to
remind council that the report is as it
stands before going out to consultation
apart from typographical and factual
errors members should focus on the
policies within the report and avoid
getting into any specific issues
relating to members wards those matters
should be raised and fed in as part of
the consultation thank you I would like
to invite councilor burn cabinet member
for planning to introduce paper MC 19:7
and moved the record and read the
recommendations in the report Thank You
mr. chairman
remember what is being presented today
is a draft joint local plan preferred
options document took out for
consultation it's the second regulation
18 stage that is proposed to be
undertaken by both mid Suffolk and baby
district councillors following the
options consultation which took place
for 12 weeks in under 2017 many comments
were made to this previous consultation
which together with engagement with
councilors changes to national policy
and guidance and a developing evidence
base have informed this version of the
document the joint local plan is made up
of three parts the first covering the
objectives and strategic policies the
second the non strategic policies also
known as development management policies
and the third covering settlement
policies site allocations and maps the
plan covers the period from the 1st of
April 2018 to the 30th of March twenty
thirty six it is important to remember
that the joint local plan must be in
conformity with the national planning
policy framework and that neighborhood
plans must also be in conformity with
the NPP f and with the strategic
priorities set out in the joint local
plan as the plan progresses towards
adoption the local plan will replace all
existing planning policies in mid
Suffolk and has common joint policies
with weber district council the housing
requirement for mid Suffolk over the
plan period is ten thousand homes and
this equates to five hundred and
fifty-six ohms per year a significant
proportion of which already have
planning permission this housing
requirement is based on the government
standard method for
lating housing need which is informed by
the 2014 based government household
projections and an affordability ratio
for the district there are four main
themes in the joint local plan covering
housing the economy the environment and
infrastructure the key housing matters
include ensuring the plan responds to
market delivery as this needs to be a
deliverable plan the reviewed settlement
hierarchy and spatial distribution will
provide greater certainty through site
allocations and settlement boundary
reviews affordability is a key issue and
the plan currently proposes 35%
affordable housing on major developments
of 10 or more homes own 0.5 hectares or
Myr more in area that is all subject to
viability
there are also policies to approach
housing design which includes meeting
space standards and adhering to building
for life criteria the spatial
distribution has been informed by
consultation feedback the availability
and deliverability of sites physical
constraints along with infrastructure
capacity and opportunities to produce
infrastruc ture vin freh structure the
plan approach is a combination of market
stroke rural balance focus and
development along strategic transport
corridors notably the a14 there is a
historic surplus of employment land with
a locational focus on the most important
strategic employment areas and
flexibility along strategic corridors
retail is prior to that prioritized to
snow market with a focus on development
within town set with intention to enter
boundary protecting and enhancing the
environment is a really important
component and there are a number of
policies that seek to achieve this
together with adapting to and mitigating
the impacts of climate change
there are also policies in respect to
biodiversity landscaped the historic
environment sustainable construction and
design and energy provision the plan
recognizes that there are capacity
existing capacity limits on
infrastructure and therefore has
incorporated evidence from an
infrastructure delivery plan which will
be published alongside the consultation
it is important that the appropriate
level of new infrastructure is secured
through new development maintaining a
focus on health education and transport
whilst ensuring the plan is viable and
deliverable you are not being applied
asked to approve this plan for adoption
I'm asking you to approve it for
consultation during that consultation
you may well also be involved in
preparing or helping others responses
I've helping others prepare responses
that might be individual residents
communities parish councils and various
groups and organizations the
consultation is open so everyone and
didn't you call it's open to everyone
and in due course when all the responses
have been considered you will have the
next stage in the production of the new
joint Local Plan the draft submission
version which will be in front of you
for approval some have suggested that
this is not ready to go out but as I've
said this is a consultation a
consultation stage and not a final
submission a couple of months delay now
we'll just add a couple of months the
final of adoption and we cannot afford
to delay any more the consultation
period falls over the summer
holiday period and for that reason
Babur District Council on Tuesday voted
to extend the extended period for a
further two weeks to give a ten week
consultation period so that gives plenty
of opportunity for comment and I am
going to suggest a small amendment to
the to the recommendation if you look at
recommendation 3.1 I'm suggesting that
it reads that the Weber and mid suffered
the draft joint Local Plan preferred
options document June 2019 Appendix A we
approved for a 10-week consultation that
will take care of the recommendations
the reason for the decision mentions an
eight week public consultation but as
that's just the reason for the decision
I don't think there's any need to alter
it there though you can if you want to
scribble the correction so I would like
to propose the recommendations set out
on page 16 recommendations three point
one and three point two that we do
approve this draft joint Local Plan for
consultation and that the corporate
manager strategic planning in
consultation with the leader of the
council and a cabinet member for
Planning be authorized to make
consequential amendments to the
consultation document arising from one
removal of drafting and technical errors
and typing mistakes and two improvements
to the layout of the document
and I can say that one of those
improvements
- the layout will be to separate the
Baber and mid Suffolk key service
centers for villages hinterland villages
Hamlet's etc out into a bay block and
amid suffer flock rather than have them
mixed together as they are at the moment
so that's it and I seek a seconder for
that motion please thank you do you have
a seconder Thank You councillor Brewster
take a minute chair yes this document
has been it appears a long time in the
coming but that is because it is
regularly picked up amendments by
government and obviously the MPP F
provision so that this plan actually is
as up-to-date as it possibly can with
you at this stage and I'm more than
happy to second counselor Berlin's
recommendations thank you very much
chair I'd like to propose an amendment
to the recommendation if I may and being
of a forward planning type of person you
will find the wording of that amendment
in your um late papers at page one and
the only slight change to that is that
the wording should say before before
noon on Friday the 5th of july 2019 so
that would give 10 days i the reason for
putting forward this amendment is that
we haven't been able to review the
allocations maps within this document
for some reason at a political level
we've been able to see the the
content of the policies but we've had no
been able to review those part of
publication but had no sight of the
allocations maps and that is something
that has raised a lot of concern amongst
communities firstly I think is extremely
disappointing and I had hoped that we
would be working with a bit more
consensus across this council and so
it's disappointing that we we haven't
had sight of those beforehand but
hopefully this amendment will help to
allay that and it'll also help to lay
the fears of communities such as those
in I and my notice that remember far is
not here today Hawley and Stowe upland
where they had neighborhood plans but
their neighborhood plan work has hasn't
been reflected in those allocation maps
and when I asked about this I was given
their kind of quote that it's all about
the data that supports this not the
communities are more about the
communities rather than the data so I
would really hope that we can accept
this amendment and I'd look for a
seconder thank you very much chair Thank
You councillor Serena Thank You chair I
would like to second the amendment and
reserve my right to speak
counselor burns you accept this
amendment yes madam chairman I'm
perfectly happy to accept it and you
know I'd like to reassure councilor
Abram that I hope that even though they
consultation or the extension that
you're asking for noon on Friday and
Friday the fifth which is a very modest
little extension that probably means
quite a bit to some people I think we
have to do that for the sake of the
people who've got to put this blend
together we are aiming for a 22nd of
July release or start for the
consultation and it would be a great
shame to delay that any further but we
we will of course be open to any
consideration during the course of the
consultation period and I would think
that the sort of changes that you're
talking about I mean the the I one for
example and the a resolution to those
those difficulties will will be found
I'm sure but it is certainly true that
whilst we are looking after our
residents and our communities here we do
have to base some of these things on on
evidence and provided sites can be found
that can be evidence to be sustainable
in the terms of this document enviable
in the terms of this document I see no
reason why those changes can't be made
into during the course of consultation
period
thank you I'll put the amendment to the
boat all those in favor and
Thank You chair just to clarify so
you're actually council has to approve
the amendment so we're putting that to
the vote then we will go back to for the
debate so you'll be able to pick up from
the original debate with the amended
emotion yeah we still have in the
Constitution it says that we have to ask
Council and the only way we can asked
you is to by voting so all those in
favor of the amendment of the amendment
reserved his right to speak and at the
moment that hasn't happened nobody else
is actually given a given the
opportunity to speak to the amendment
chair through you it's because I'm
counselor burn accepted that amendment
therefore there is no debate thank you
so all those in favor of the vote in
favor of the amendments thank you guys
carried right we'll return to the
original report as amended and um and we
can begin the debate
I'm positive powerful yeah no yes
um this isn't this is really a question
one of the really important things if we
have any consultation about anything in
in public life it's really important
that it is meaningful and that we listen
to what people say and try and address
their concerns and that's going to be
one heck of a challenge anything to do
with planning I suspect you could have
infinite views about everything so I
really wanted to ask the portfolio in
order to work with people and bring
communities along with us just in public
your your your views that we this will
really be a meaningful consultation
that's not meant to be a sitting
question because I think some people get
very very skeptical about consultations
all over the place so I really do hope
we will be able to work together and
make a tangible difference improvement
and
to the proposals at the moment one of
the things I'm concerned about I'll be
looking at carefully personally and with
those in our ward things like water
resources scarce natural resources and
how we can work together on that and the
other issue that I've always had about
and planning it's it's a guideline it is
not absolutely set in stones very
important document but of course there
are villages and more remote communities
that sometimes do want some development
and so on we need to spread this out to
work with everybody particularly about
giving opportunities for young people I
probably ought to say first-time buyers
now to get on that on the housing ladder
and it's really important that we are
able to help deliver that as a council
because certainly it's about opportunity
for people all those who wish to get on
the property ladder as well as those who
obviously wish to rent properties I'm
councillor Madison's first oh I got the
first joke oh sorry I thought we can't
account for streamers before me yeah I
just wanted to thank thank the chair
first and and then to thank Council that
burned for responding to to one of the
particular points that the the joint
member working group picked up with was
to actually separate out the two sets of
settlements and in fact I think quite a
number of other things have been amended
and that that that process was very
collaborative with between members
irrespective of politics and the
officers and that was all very
productive which is makes it all the
more disappointing that they're not the
same has been carried out as regards the
maps in fact in the working group we
were promised the the maps a week
earlier the name fact emerged so so that
that's the downside unfortunate
councillor stringer thanks Jay
now that I'm not gonna risk losing the
amendment I'll use it I'll use most of
the speech I was going to use what's
really interesting about this process is
I was involved in that in the working
party looking at the written word and
the written word of this paper is
something I'm immensely proud of and
it's probably one of the single best
things this council's done in a number
of years what's a real pity is that we
lost it right at the end by publishing a
completely flawed set of maps and the
reason they're flawed is not picking
holes in officers work that they're done
I've really applauded all the work
that's been done it's because publishing
the maps in the way that we have now
published them proves to a number of
communities that for the last two years
we've completely ignored them and I'm
not talking about huge allocation is
amours it's those smaller communities
that were in Courage two years ago
please put your submissions into this
council but where we can move a
settlement boundary around so then so
you can have a small amount of
development in your settlements quite
right thing to do so all the ones I
represented we had a good old
consultation loads of pictures up in
village halls thank you to the team for
sublimely some very large maps really
helpful we gave that information back
over 18 months ago and since then there
has been radio silence right up until
the point these documents were then
published the second I saw them I
pleaded with both portfolio holders on
both sides of these two councils to
please don't publish because it will
cause damage the damage is already being
caused I have a number of resignations
from parish councils already and it's a
huge shame that we had a brilliant
document right at the start and we've
lost it by publishing so early to some
of these communities and why it's so
ridiculous
so we've now put settlement boundaries
in some very small locations where the
only place that apparently they can now
have developed in the future is in their
children's play area we've ignored the
brownfield sites that identified to us
completely ignored them and put them put
the site where this gorgeous 150 yard
oak tree and it's like it's really like
you know we've just we've lost it
the last so I hope that we can in very
short term redress some of these
anomalies and get these ironed out
pretty pretty quick because actually I
agree with the leader in her interview
on the television the other day when
asked what it's like to negotiate
policies within a relatively hung
Council the leader said it means you
need to discuss a lot more upfront
rather than wait till you get to the
chamber I really wish we did discuss
them the proposals maps in here an awful
lot more up front or indeed at all that
front Thank You councillor Byrne would
you like to answer a noob at first of
all can I just respond to councillor
first more if he could remind me what he
said always been meaning meaningful over
they'll be taking into account other
words even if by all means certainly
from my point of view it has to be
meaning what is the point of a
consultation
it's a 10-week consultation to lengthy
but both by normal standards a lengthy
one we're open to anything from
everybody we're bound by statute as you
well know in certain cases and things
some things are just not possible
but I don't see why most things can't be
possible on this on this occasion I mean
if we want some Tom Tom are you willing
to add anything to to that so far as the
answer to to else a person was concerned
yep through you Jen
yes I mean that the as counselor burner
said that the consultation is a genuine
one we've extended the period the the
absolute anticipation is that we act in
accordance with a range of other
policies that the counselors had
counseled adopted its statement of
community involvement on planning
matters it also in March adopted its
community strategy both of those things
point strongly towards listening to our
communities reflecting what it is that
they want I recognize that there's some
tension between saying that and the
comments by Councillor stringer about
responses to the previous consultation
and but I think we have to pick those up
with him individually separately but it
is absolutely a meaningful consultation
and the more that we hear from our
communities the more evidence that we
have of what our communities really want
the more weight that we have to
represent their desires as we take a
document into examination process thank
you
and councillor Madison I think that it
is going to be very important in future
for us to collaborate as closely and as
openly as possible with members of the
opposition and I will certainly for my
car try to make sure that that does
happen
Kosar stringer a flawed set of maps yes
in some cases I believe that possibly
the case probably certainly the case
sorry I don't mean to be flippant by
saying possibly the case it may well be
the case I don't think it proves that
we've ignored it your communities and
and I do think that it in our present
present position it gives us the
opportunity of listening to your
communities yet again if I can put it
that way it's a shame from your point of
view that we have to but
I think it is possible that some of the
maps can be redrawn to go around your
150 year old oak trees and I'm not sure
I think I think such things are
important that Flay areas we ought not
to be developing when there are
brownfield sites close by if that if
that proves to be possible then I'm sure
we will do our best to accommodate you
on that you counselor field Thank You
chair my view I really think is that the
local planners many years overdue within
a sufficient resource of light and
government delays and revision @cm PPF
have not helped we've been left to
expose to speculative market driven
developments proposals in a supposedly
plain LED environment that actually
lacks an up-to-date plan many of our
wards have suffered development
residents would have us resist in an
environment where the number of houses
that must be accommodated and the
expected distribution across the
districts have just not been known my
group believes that it's essential to
get development back to a plan led
position as soon as it's reasonably
possible and for that reason support the
idea that the current document should go
to consultation further months of delay
would leave all you build for the next
20 years determine before the plan is
completed however we do have some
significant reservations and issues that
we feel should be addressed firstly the
recent progress has been rushed and I
doubt that many of us have given the
document the attention and detailed
examination it warrants and might be
particularly true of new councillors it
must be clear that we are not going to
be told later on that there's no
significant deviations from the current
text just topographical collections and
minor changes to
language and that's all that can be
accommodated without invalidating the
process I hope that the answers to
Council pass more question means that's
not so but it's a fear something of a
certainly experienced in the past
I feel the maps have some defects I
haven't looked at the mix extensively as
perhaps councillor stringer house but
developments already approved are not
shown on one of the plans and in some
areas village boundaries have not been
extended to cover those developments
already approved in fact some that are
currently being built out that gives a
false impression of the status of such
developments secondly developments
rejected by development travel are shown
in the plan as proposals without any
differentiation for those yet to be
considered this will give a false view
to developers and probably inspectors
that it is reasonable for all in the
ministrations wish that such sites
should progress the course of action for
neighborhood plans adopted or closing
closing in on that status should also be
made clear we do not want to see
dramatic changes in numbers destroy the
value of commit dedicated community work
or to encourage the view that such plans
are a waste of time however neither
would we want to see them as a
successful move to resist development
based on housing allocations that are
known to be low I'm not absolutely clear
whether the green amendment really
resolves all my issues I guess with the
extension of the time by a small amount
I'm inclined to move more in that
direction but I would point out that
Friday the 5th is the end of next week
and a number of us are actually off on a
conference which I hope is hard work not
to jolly but I'm sure it will take most
of our
and that we all need to contribute to
that particular process I personally
feel that if we approve that if we're
meant today as a minimum some covering
notes you should go with it that points
out those issues particularly the one
that says that plans that are have been
rejected once or twice perhaps by this
council should not be given the same
weight by any other authority for
instance and planning inspector as areas
that are purely new have not yet been
discussed in any serious way so on that
basis I guess certainly I will be
supporting the document but as you've
heard with considerable reservations and
we're hope that we can get some real
progress over the next week Thank You
councillor Carter sat here as I am I
have a genuine fear of going through
this document we appear to be no I'm
just failing to misunderstand but
fundamentally damaging any trust that we
might have from certain communities we
are nodding towards local government
with the local neighbor plans but we are
not acknowledging there's basic needs of
members of within our community and
that's because passports say before that
there are certain people who have a a1a
need to be on the housing list but from
what I understand there are many many
more people who would give anything to
be on the housing list to be able to
afford to be actually the to move up an
owner property who have many jobs but
we're not no matter how low we get the
housing no matter how low we've set for
a bar for a price they're not going to
be entertainers we are we need to be
doing much more for be social housing
genuine social social housing and we
need to be addressing these four but we
need to be addressing the holes in the
floor where our own trying to pave over
them so you know I just do have a fear
that we're doing this we're going to be
expensive the extensive funding
extensive resources into a document
which is outdated and not representative
of what we really needed it was current
date counselor do you want to come back
to it um well I'd like to come back to a
small extent on councilor feels council
appeals comments I accept that
the end of next week is not very far
away and there's a distinct limit to
what what we can expect to board members
to submit by way of correction to the
maps and but what isn't court next week
can certainly be caught in the next ten
weeks or the ten weeks following the
22nd of July and I certainly hope it
would be for reassurance that sites that
we've already refused are not included
in the plan thereby if they are giving
giving inspectors a false impression of
our opinion of them as it were I asked
Tom
Rob Rob to answer that one if he will
but before he does can I just say to
come to the Carter that your points are
well made I'm not sure how much the
local plan as it stands can address them
the fact that it's cost a considerable
amount of money to get this far and it
will cost yet more to complete the job
it's certainly true but it is something
that we just have to do we cannot avoid
that and so it isn't it isn't
expenditure that could be steered in in
a different direction however in
important that direction might be and I
don't doubt the importance of the
direction you were talking about I will
just discuss it with the officers and
see how we might be able to address
those things but thank you for making
the points anyway could I ask Rob Hobbs
to respond to council food thank you for
you chair I just remind councillors that
this local plan has a base day at the
1st of April 2018 the sites that have
been granted Planning Commission since
that date won't the sweetpea well they
won't be shown in the maps unless they
were identified previously in the
strategic housing and employment and
availability assessment and also that
for hinterlands and Hamlet's
the settlement boundary has been drawn
around sites that would have had
planning permission but they aren't
shown because we're not showing site
allocations at that level and can also
remind councillors that settlement site
allocations is a is what the doke plan
that seeks to do some allocations as
I've just luta will have planning
permission some will not but in terms of
the weight is applied if this plan is
approved by council with
it will have a limited way because it's
still quite an early stage in the plan
process silletti been and thank you very
much chair I've just wanted to ask about
the subject to get up neighborhood plans
firstly it's a shame I think that this
document wasn't published in March I
think this has been a long time in
coming and we should have got this
looking out for consultation before the
local elections and I see there was no
reason no good reason to to delay it to
until now but I do feel that the
communities that I represent feel that
they've been ignored given that they've
put a lot of work into their
neighborhood plans and this hasn't been
represented in in this document in fact
to the point that when they looked at
their document they just said why should
we respond if I if our comments you know
all the work we've done on a
neighborhood plan hasn't been taken into
account thus far is it even worth us
responding with which of course I I say
yes you know absolutely everybody should
respond but I think communities feel
they've undertaken work on neighborhood
plans in good faith but yet it's not
been shown that within these documents
to date and but I will be voting for
this tonight because I do feel this
should have been put forward long ago
and definitely before the elections and
it's a shame it's just taken so long to
get to this stage Thank You councillor
Willem Thank You chair
as expected I want to say a few words
about snow upland because people is so
up from were flabbergasted when they saw
the plan with the two unexpected large
housing sites so I just want to say a
little bit about those one of them has
been a recent planning application in
respect of that piece of land for up to
60 homes and this is this was fully and
by a fairly aggressive developer not
to snow upland and as part of that
application for 60 homes that
prospective developer offered a lovely
meadow which has got local significance
invited it offered that as a gift to the
parish now we see that the draft
proposals map has encompassed that into
a building site and suggested a hundred
it would be such a shame if we lost that
that meadow but I fear the damage is
done because it is now shown as a
potential housing site and I think we
should have been a bit more careful
about how we how we drew those Maps I
leave it there I'm really I'm really
worried that we're doing this sort of
thing another plot in the village and it
covers and covers the allotments well we
ought to be protecting allotments not
suggesting house as a built in it's
tricky Thank You chair could I just ask
for some clarification around how much
weight in planning terms the joint local
plan has now that it's in the public
domain the draft joint local plan has
noticed in the public domain and how
that will change once it's sent forward
for for consultation will join it answer
this
through your chairman at the moment will
have limited waiting planning decisions
that weight will grow as the plan
emerges and go through the consultation
process and we have today for example in
relation to an appeal in I in relation
to land which is allocated here we've
clarified that position to the inspector
in our submissions on that appeal so it
will evolve and change but at the
present point in time and until it's and
until it progresses further decisions
will inevitably have to attract limited
weight to this document at present point
in time Thank You councillor Guthrie
thank you yes a couple of points I'm
sure listening to the debate from my
colleagues they were saying that this
should have come through before the
election well I think actually Rob and
Shaw can answer why that didn't come
forward because there were certain bits
of information that they were still
collating and it would have been
inappropriate at that time so I'm sure
that can be answered at a later date
as regards the the maps that have come
out yes indeed it was unfortunate that
they've come out late but I've made a
note of what I need to say and I'm sure
we've got 40 councillors here that can
all make their notes and hopefully with
the extension that's been recommended
that we can all get that information
back quickly enough so I do think whilst
time is of the essence I think we will
all have the opportunity to put the the
emotions if we need any amendments on
the maps thank you thank you would
anyone else like to speak so David do
you want to do is sort of summing up
well it does occur to me I think that
one or two of the speakers have not been
answered councillor he burned your
dissapointed neighborhood plan compilers
yes I fully understand that and the risk
of you thinking I'm sitting on the wrong
side of the floor I I do rather agree
with that comment and however having
said that you it has to be realized that
we we draw a line we have to draw a line
at a particular point so far as
developing this plan is concerned the
development of neighborhood plans
they're all they've all started at
different times rolling around
in a tumbler at the moment and some are
at later stages than others the the ones
that is that are not yet formulated we
can't do anything about the ones that
have had their made their allocations
given their decisions but have not yet
reached a stage of submission we can we
can certainly think think about those
but I think one of the officers would be
better place than I am to answer that
that particular question
I might ask Tom or Rob Rob Rob would
like to do that in in just a minute
Keith I don't believe the damage has
been done already I think it can be I
think it can be healed I think we can
improve matters so far as big things
like you're still upland plan and
allocating sites that unsuitable if you
think that's the case but as I said
before however it's evidence that will
count as to whether these can be altered
in the plan itself and of counselor geek
that you've you've had your answer I
think to the weight of the plan waiting
any decisions on the basis of evidence
is extremely difficult in planning as
you usually know anyway and and just you
can't quantify it that's the difficulty
it's got a little weight or it's got
more weight and another one but that's
about all you can say at the moment is
as
the counselor I'm sorry officer Holmes
[Laughter]
it doesn't have much by the time the
consultation ends and the consultation
results are incorporated it will have
quite considerably more though it wasn't
office the homes it was officer Isabella
thank you for that summing up I think
there been a lot of useful comments I
think that we will take them all on
board I think we will be able to satisfy
quite a number of them others may be a
little difficult but we'll do our best
and certainly I will put whatever weight
I can behind making sure that the local
plan does reflect neighborhood plans as
accurately as possible because
neighborhood plans are something I feel
quite passionate about I don't think the
processes is foolproof I think the
government could improve matters there
in the fullness of time but the Localism
Act as it stands it doesn't make it any
easier for us but anyway we are trying
to approve a plan for consultation not
approve the plan itself that's the main
that's the main thrust of this evening
so thank you very much for listening and
for all your contributions so what do
you want to say anything
Thank You chair yeah I'd like to say
something on labor plans
if I may just remind the number one they
were plans being prepared before the
joint local planners reached this stage
and we're knowledge that some of these
has been produced without an indicative
housing requirement figure this was
introduced there following the NPP F in
2018 and what we've been doing is
without the figure we've been responding
to the consort
regulation 14 stage and being trying to
provide an indicative number or at least
commenting to say that maybe the plan
isn't providing for enough or perhaps
needs to have another site put in and
this is all on record so on page 43 to
44 we've now published indicative
required to write a minimum labor plan
figures for all those areas producing a
neighbor plan which you can guide Ida
production and also we would like to
continue to work with neighborhood plan
groups and we are intending to have
meetings with neighborhood fanger is
very soon it's part of the consultation
as they continue to develop their
neighborhood plans alongside the joint
local plan and we fully anticipated the
next stage in local plan would then
incorporate more detail from those
neighborhood plans a theme progressed
further can also respond to to council
Welham on the point about the meadow
policy LP 28 on page 127 and joined
local plan since that there's a noted
open spaces will will be there protected
in the same ways designated open space
is it in the local plan so those
identified and they plan to have the
protection it's just not shown on the
map so the policies are in place and
equally the to the site's being proposed
in slow up and can be developed in a way
that green space is a key key um
component all those allocations because
the allocation is for the site area and
with the indicative housing requirement
identified within the planet I'd say
thank you we have um we have had the
summing up so I'm just going to go for
the vote so all those in favor of the
recommendations as amended
okay that's Kerry thank you I'm moving
on to UM agenda item 10 MC slash 19
slash 8 the publication of the mid
Suffolk housing delivery test action
plan I would like to invite counsel
counsel a burn cabinet member for
planning to introduce the paper MC 19
slash 8 and moved the recommendations in
the report
chairman housing delivery is a
recognized national issue various
government initiatives have been
undertaken have undertaken reform of the
planning system to help stimulate and
support increased levels of house
building the housing delivery test was
published in February 2000 and 19 this
measures the net additional dwellings
provided within a local authority area
against the number of dwellings required
over the previous three years and shows
the performance for each local authority
in England the housing delivery test
results identified mid Suffolk districts
as achieving 80% 81 percent of the total
number of dwellings required over the
period first of april 2015 to 31st of
March 2018 in addition the housing the
housing delivery test national results
the mid suffer require the addition of a
20% buffer to the figure of 556 per year
in calculating the five-year housing
land supply requirement as a consequence
of not meeting 95% of this housing
requirement the council is required now
to produce a housing delivery test
action plan within six months from
February 2019
so that is by August of 2019 we have to
publish this housing delivery test
action plan and it's to incorporate a
range of measures that will support
increased housing delivery Appendix A to
this report represents mid suffix
housing delivery test action plan which
also incorporates data in the form of
appendix want thereby meeting this
requirement I draw your attention to the
general recommendations on pages 43 and
44 is the lending test hopefully the
same in this one Paris Lee point four
and three point five is that correct yes
and particularly the 15 bullet points on
page four whoops page 1 to 5 of our
papers now also please note the section
on sale which is a story about this it's
just run transcribing from a baby paper
[Applause]
[Applause]
I will say on page 109 thank you miss
summary this is something we had to do
and it's been done so I move the
recommendation for approval for a second
- thank you thank you do I have a
seconder I'm happy to set this chair
thank you this is this is now open for
questions and debate councillor stringer
thank Jennifer first I have a question
before I want to say any more could I
ask who carries out the actions within
the report that says work being carried
out now who carries it out at the moment
and who's going to carry out in the
future
cancer burnt II have a response
Christine would you like to respond to
that yes through your chair so the
actions in the housing delivery test
action plan there are 23 of them in
total 15 of these are taken from the
joint homes and housing strategy which
has already been through Council and
that is a continuation of that work for
the housing delivery test action plan we
took into account a wide range of data
which informed the actions we used the
services of a consultant to give us
housing market intelligence in terms of
taking these actions forward we are
forming a group of officers which will
be taken across a wide spread at the
council to reflect the different work
streams that they are and that is being
set up at the moment
councillor Madison oh sorry
cancer-stricken sorry chair with the
greatest respect that I don't feel my
questions been answered who is doing it
and who is going to do it through chat
so there is there will be officers from
the strategic planning team there will
be officers from a development
management team and also from the
strategic housing team really to reflect
the work streams that are either already
triggered and started all the new ones
which will be coming forward as a result
of the study that some been put together
councillor Mansell Thank You chair I
would just like to comment on the table
which is on page 135 of the document
which is a table listing the number of
stalled sites and I would just like a
bit of clarity on the numbers in that
time
I am assuming perhaps incorrectly that
these are the stall sites that have a
live planning application currently and
I just wanted to know if they included
ones that already had elapsed planning
permission and if there are some with a
lapsed planning permission do we have
the numbers of the ones that elapsed
thank you what we did in terms of
constructing a working database of the
amount of sites that we had was we
looked at everything with an outline
planning permission anything with an
outline planning permission and a
reserve matters anything with a full
planning permission where no
commencement had started we also picked
up one site where commencement had
started and then stopped so it's a
widely changing as you're probably aware
database in that planning permissions
are added all the while and things which
lacks get left off by the same token so
this is something that in terms of data
we fixed at the end of March beginning
of April this year in order to give to
the housing delivery consultant who who
looked at the specialist work what we
needed them to do and clearly moving
forward with the housing delivery test
action plan this database will continue
to be built on Thank You counselor man
so trying to come back please thank
thank you for that
I understand it's it may just be a
snapshot in time of March this year but
I don't think the questions been
answered because those planning
applications that have elapsed
presumably if there are no change to
material considerations for planning
will probably get their planning
permission renewed quite easily and
they're not included so I wanted to know
whether there was a large proportion of
sites that have got
that's planning permission whether it is
similar to the numbers that I've got
live planning applications or whether
we're only talking about a half a dozen
I don't know okay three hm thank you
the situation with delivery is now that
it is a material consideration in the
determination of planning applications
for those sites which have elapsed
permissions it's true that that is a
material consideration and we are
entitled to weigh up whether or not
development and deliverability is
actually going to be achieved at any
realistic point in time so we're a site
has not come forward we do expect to ask
applicants extremely seriously what
their intentions are and to weigh and
take into account their delivery record
in the district elsewhere we have we are
we are building and have a good level of
intelligence around that and continue to
develop that so the answer is we will
not simply as a matter of course be
seeking to renew permissions that have
been granted we will obviously consider
them on their merits but the delivery
record of any developer or applicant we
will take into account and where
appropriate we will either recommend a
very short timetable for implementation
we may decide that the site is now
actually potentially going to come
forward in a realistic prospect and look
elsewhere Thank You councillor Orton and
yeah on page one to five or page 21 of
the document it says more actively
linked registered providers with land
promoters I think that's extremely
important but I need to be assured that
the council does have the relevant data
and that data is correct because I think
it's important that we know who all of
those registered land the providers are
and where they already do have
properties also bit further down
ensuring applications are approved on
time and section
it's agreement assigned of absolutely we
would agree with that
but it must not be without due
consideration I would hope that speed is
not given over against quality
councillor Carter councillor strings
earlier question are to apologize just
going through my head trying to work
outs we have another question was
answered easiest work currently being
carried out and who is actually doing it
I understand that it's going to be done
by team and consults in the future but
it's just currently current is this
being done who's doing it and if not why
not
Ekstrom do you want to get this it's
throw you chair I think it's it's quite
difficult in the meeting to tease apart
because there are 23 different actions
some of those actions are being
undertaken by particular individuals
some are being undertaken by other
individuals some of them are work
already in train some of them are work
that is still to be done so just to take
an example ensuring a smarter and
improved prep education process that's
firmly within the realms of development
management there is a very application
system we have now run to surveys of the
users of that pre application system to
understand to help us to continue to
refine it so that it remains an
effective pre-application process that
informs applications and ensures that
when they come in we can deal with them
as effectively as possible viability
testing of proposed land allocations at
plan making stage that has been
undertaken that is part of the evidence
base that informs the document that
you've just approved to go out to
consultation ensuring applicable they're
approved on time and section 106
agreements are signed off promptly
that's a relationship between our
planning offices our legal team our
strategic housing team our public realm
team and a range of others our
environmental health team depending on
the specific requirements within any
given
one over six and the requirement for
those offices to work effectively with
the developer of any given scheme so I
can say that certainly those actions
which are described as work in progress
it's predominantly a relationship
between our strategic planning team our
infrastructure team and our development
management team with other offices
pulled in as aware necessary mid Suffolk
council did approve some one off funding
to address student sites one of the
challenges that we had was recruiting to
that so if councillor stringer was
seeking comfort that there was
additional resource to drive forward
delivery we were unable to recruit to
the post that we did design and put out
for agreement twice the funding for that
was used to engage Navitus planning
private consultancy firm who have
advised us on market intelligence and
some of the actions that are proposed in
there such as have an annual conference
with developers having a closer
relationship with registered providers
and those kind of things
Julie I'll be Taylor's team that the
housing the enabling team do have close
relationships with registered providers
pickup counselor on this point I can't
say if absolutely certain that they know
every single one that exists but they
certainly have strong relationships with
a range of registered providers and I'm
happy to pick that point up with you
outside the meeting so that we can give
you the confidence that that team know
all of the are peas that are operating
within our area certainly as part of the
housing conference that isn't is that
it's happening on the 11th of July that
will be another mechanism and there are
a range of mechanisms to ensure that
we're working closely with the industry
one of the things that development
management had very effectively put in
place over the last couple of years is
what we call the client side panel which
again is is a means through which
officers can ensure that there is a
strong working relationship with
planning agents house builders
developers and land promoters who all
attend those so that we're getting as
much kind of real-time information about
how the market is operating how our
services are operating so that we ensure
that we do find the right
it's fulfilling our role effectively as
a regulator and ensuring that we make
sound legal decisions but also that we
make those in a timely way to ensure
that we aren't the cause of holdups
within the planning process
Thank You councillor Scott thank you
well like any action plan we have work
in progress an action plan required I
feel towards the end of the document
there are rather too many action plan
required notations in particular
regarding the three categories of
stallers so I would like to know what is
the process because it says that the
action is prior to the annual review of
this housing delivery test an action
plan we know we actually like to see
some progress on these action plans and
would it be wise to ask perhaps that we
could have perhaps a three-month an
update to members in some shape or form
whether it be to the council or to
members for a briefing session because
progress from our point of view is
difficult to measure unless we have a
time scale yes do you check one thing
that we could do is ensure that as part
of the cabinet members quarterly update
reporting to councillors at full council
that we ensure that we update on the
actions that moving forward in the heels
and delivery tests as part of that
regular update Thank You councillor eben
thank you very much chair I appreciate
that this is a work that we we have to
do the government's asked us to do and I
would like to get some comfort that we
are that work is going on before side
stall as opposed to kind of waiting to
before we're we realize that starts have
stalled and just that there I just do
need the sort of degree of comfort in
terms of again with weird I think we're
talking around a lot of the same matters
here which is around capacity really is
that officers working on this presumably
have got day jobs and are actually this
is work that they're doing in addition
to their
they're their normal working day and can
I have some assurance and perhaps this
is from the that the leader and perhaps
the chief exec that if more stuff is
required or needed than that they will
get them in order to fulfill the
requirements of this document because
obviously well it is something that
governments asking us to do it will
actually benefit the council to actually
achieve the action plan within this and
I'm just very conscious that there's no
star SAS around idling at the moment and
that you know there's a lot of work that
needs to be done here and just the
comfort that they will be able to if
more staff are needed further capacities
needed that that will be available and
will be asked for and won't be seen as a
failure to ask for it either
because we've got to ensure that this is
this is done and done into completeness
thank you thank you chairman and as it
was thrown to me I think probably
probably that I respond and certainly
firstly thank you to Casa de Beaune for
confirming that there's certainly no
staff idling around there there are
absolutely extremely busy and having
said that this is not supplementary to
the day job this is part of the day job
and certainly for all of our approaches
around growth and development it's been
the case for a long time that is not
about granted plan for missions it's
about seeing houses actually built and I
would say that whilst we've had to
produce this document by virtue of a
government initiative this council was
here first because you were already
talking about stalled sites and there
needed to take activity long before
government decided that we need to
compose it in a specific action plan so
the short answer to your questions can
be burners yes Thank You councillor
stringer yep take a chair it's very sort
of timely actually that I was chosen now
and before I go on to I say what I'm
gonna say now councillor burns started
it your submission off by saying it's a
hugely recognized national issue
actually failure to delivering on
delivering houses is hugely recognized
locally because when you fall into
deficit in housing delivery it gets
noticed through the planning system when
to some
cause concerns all help begins to break
loose
and we've seen some of the worst extents
of that in mid suffered and and I hope I
never see some of that again so that's
why I was asking the question as to
who's doing the work now and who's going
to be the doing the work in the future
because I have some serious concerns
about workload within the current system
and situation and it's actually
reflected in the consultation a
consultant's report here it says that we
lag behind a lot lot of other
authorities in how long it takes us to
achieve planning permission well I'm
concerned about that if an awful lot of
these action plans to be required action
plan required is going to be putting
extra work on the very team that will
need to be delivering those planning
permissions which is why I think five
budgets in a row we asked you to
consider resource it into this and then
two years ago you agreed and I encourage
others to agree with your budget for
that year but of course we failed to
recruit to the post and the reason we
failed to the recruit to the post is to
be only operative one year there aren't
many people gonna be jumping into a job
if it's just seen as one year so I would
like to propose an amendment and it's
three-point-three that says sufficient
resources be found to make sure the
outcomes of this plan be met and I'm the
second council cautery
second Inglis um David are you happy to
accept this
it sounds good to me and but I'm not the
I would have to refer to the chief exec
on this one he still thinks he's the is
the man in charge when it comes to
employing stone thank chairman just to
give reassurance to a council when you
make decisions that's my job to find the
resources to implement all such
decisions but absolutely yes and if that
means that I need to come back to you
and say you can't afford to do this
instead in order to deliver this then I
will do that but I don't foresee it
being a challenge so I'm from my
perspective it's not up to me but from
my perspective the recommendation the
amendment is fun the council at birth
and then give some to accept just before
each one muster say something so yes
just just prior to the the amendment
there were a couple of items a couple of
areas where I thought it might be useful
to reassure councillors so the
consultants report does talk about the
length of time it takes to ground
Planning Commission one statistic that
just came across my emails very recently
was around planning performance
particularly what is often reported to
councillors is the proportion or the
percentage of applications that are
determined in time and that's the kind
of 13 week 16 week deadline for
approving major application schemes one
thing that isn't always reported and one
of the things that we'll be looking to
bring into the quarterly performance
monitoring is the median number of days
for granting those planning applications
and to show a direction of travel I
think it's useful perhaps to describe
during 2017 the average number of days
of major schemes was 130 during 2018 it
100
35 days during since the beginning of
the year the average time taken is 80
days
there's been a significant improvement
in the average speed at which those
major schemes are brought forward and
determined and the legal agreements
sorted and the actual decision issued
the other thing which made reassured
consulars and you be some comfort around
those actions that are already entrained
and some of the things that have been
happening recently to drive forward
delivery the council ism is required to
publish its annual monitoring report and
its five-year housing housing land
supply statement and we're currently
working it up there's still some
finessing to do with some of the details
on that but the one thing which we do
know at the moment is the number of
completions and it's obviously more
complicated than just the completions
but within mid Suffolk we're looking at
a number closer to 700 than 400 in terms
of completions so there's a significant
uplift over the last year which shows
that some of our more significant
schemes are really now starting to come
through and deliver the housing that
your residents really need thank you but
before we go back to the debate and I've
got everyone who wants to answer
questions we were going to vote on the
on the amendment so all those in favor
of the amendment that's carried right we
can go back to the debate and I believe
that Alan Tim Council to pass more your
next yep thank you very much madam
chairman it really builds on the keys
point earlier just a suggestion I think
it'd be helpful with the action plan
given the resources and everything else
are coming together if it were possible
in that update to try and tidy up
particularly and I think is eight points
that appear to be dependent on the the
annual review if you could give an
indicative date that would help you help
us to see how progress is going forwards
all right is a public document and I've
been in other situations where it can be
sometimes a little bit vague not quite
crisp enough and then things drift and I
know you're all working extremely hard
on that but with Arthur's
fresh mandate of resources and so on I'm
sure it won't be a problem and I think
we don't benefit from them
Thank You councillor Miller thank you
madam chair and I very much welcome the
introduction of this action plan and all
the the work and the action is going
gonna go on with it and bearing in mind
my colleague Kansas cough comments a few
months ago can I suggest that we bring
this and look at it as a scrutiny
committee before the end of the year
thank you as for field Thank You chair
and when faced with a vast list of
things to do I always find a good
question in these which ones do you
actually intend to complete ie which
ones are actually gonna make a
difference which this seems as say a
vast list some things though I discharge
planning conditions promptly is
something that one probably a guest
would help but are there any others in
this great list that you're actually are
gonna be significant q councillor
Welling Thank You chair I'm kind of
touched on some of the points I was
going to make that my concern is and I
hear this from small builders that one
of the holdouts is around the section
106 ease and getting the legal
agreements all sorted out we need to
make sure that there is sufficient
resources on the legal side not just on
the planning side that's one of the
queries I thought and the other is yeah
we're making good progress on getting
our planning application sorted the big
ones in less time but what we don't want
to do is to move people from that making
sure it stays like that to do other work
when perhaps what we really need for
some of the action points is people with
different skills different from the
skills that are present in the in the
authority at present so we need to be
looking to see whether that is a way
forward and the other point is page 125
one of the possible and one of the
recommendations is we should create a
flexible approach to tenure mix to
accelerate delivery I've got real
concerns about this there's a real need
for social and affordable rent houses
and we don't want those to be lost in
this flexible approach cost more to do
you want to speak okay if no one else
wants to speak will move to the boat so
all those in favor of the
recommendations as amended all those
against right that's carried by moving
on to item number 11
MC / 19 / 9 stay up from Neighborhood
Development Plan I would like to invite
councillor burn cabinet member for
planning to introduce his paper and move
the recommendations in the report
thank you report before you updates
Council on the progress of the East
Auckland neighbourhood plan it
recommends that the neighbourhood plan
be formally made that is adopted as part
of this council's development plan
following a majority yes vote at the
recent local referendums and that the
decision statement to this effect be
published with immediate effect work on
this neighbourhood plan commenced in
February - in 2015 the plan has been
through an extensive period of
preparation through two rounds of formal
public consultation and has been
independently examined cabinet colleague
colleagues may recall seeing a report on
this plan when it was agreed that it be
advanced to the local rhetoric
referendum the plan was modified in
accordance with the examiners
recommendations and the referendum took
place on the 6th of June section 4 of
the report provides key information
about the
including the format of the question
that was asked of those entitled to vote
and the paragraph 4.3 the declared
result the total number of votes cast
was 419 an approximate 25 percent
turnout number of yes votes cast was 388
which amounted to a 93 percent of the
total votes cast the number of no votes
cast was 30 approximately 7 percent and
the number of void ballot papers one
paragraph four point six of the report
refers to the final draft decision
statement a copy of which is appended to
this report the copy will be sent to the
Parish Council and also published on the
appropriate page in our website
[Applause]
section five and six of the report
provide details of the financial and
legal implications of the decision to
adopt this plan the decision today means
that the stove upland neighbourhood plan
becomes the fourth neighbourhood plan to
be formally adopted in mid Suffolk as
such it becomes part of the development
plan framework for the designated area
which is the parishes to upland and will
be used to help determine planning
applications where relevant
I commend this neighbourhood plan to you
and I ask that the council endorses the
recommendations set out at the end of
the report thank you thank you could I
have a seconder
sorry I was a bit slow there yes thank
you actually I'm happy to second that
and I'd like to congratulate the stove
up the neighborhood plan working group
on their work and and also to thank Paul
and Paul for their help and advice and
also thank the 419 people who actually
turned out to vote that the third time
in five weeks
yes that's happy to second that and I'd
like to see see this brought into the
planning framework as soon as possible
thank you would anyone else like to
speak so we'll go to the boat then all
those in favor
that's unanimous
thanks very much item number 12
MSC slash 19 slash 10 nominations
through appointment of directors to the
board of mid suffered off for holdings
limited I'd like to invite councillor
Brewster chair of mid Suffolk District
Council Holdings Limited to introduce
the paper and to move the recommendation
in the report thing about chair yes and
as this report proposes the election of
three new directors councillors Rick
mayor Peter Gould and Paul F neon to the
board of the mid Suffolk District
Council Suffolk Holdings Limited to fill
post that were vacated by former counsel
is Glenn horn and counsel James story
and additionally cancer Matthew Hicks
who initially came on to the board with
the promise of a month to ensure we've
got resilience over the election period
as indicated he's wished to step down
from the board the election of new
directors to the holding company will
ensure robust governance of the company
structure that is retained I look
forward to the opportunity of working
with counselors mayor Gore and it be on
on the holding company and I propose the
recommendation at 3.1
with the reason given it 3.2 and I seek
a second degrees a second
thank you yes happy to second counselor
eben
thank you very much chair and can I ask
where these positions were advertised
firstly and secondly could somebody
answer the question with regards to
political proportionality in this case
thank you I don't believe there is the
need and I'll stand corrected but I
don't think there is a need for prudent
and political brush nobility and the
it's normal for the directors of the
board to nominate the people to
recommend to the Council for approval
Chancellor Hicks think I just like so
thoroughly enjoyed my brief tenure with
the companies but I think one has to
recognize when they're more qualified
people that come forward in the council
and I think we have three examples of
people who are qualified committed and
want to put it in the time and energy
and have the time to do so so I really
welcome the fact that councillor Peter
gold cancer RIT mayor and council Paul
Epping young have come forward and happy
to take this place I think it's good to
recognize people that could do a fine
job and probably better than you in such
circumstances thank you
I'm counselor field thank you I suppose
there's one comment really at accepting
and understanding those comments
we have little actual knowledge of the
skills of the gentlemen concerned I hope
they're more than adequate and
but the skills audit information for
instance is not is not valuable and I
sum up new counselors we barely have
significant knowledge of their
capabilities I did just want to ask that
it says the comment was that the
existing directors nominate new
directors bearing in mind that there
were some directors who were not
reelected and what a number of people
were involved in that decision I didn't
say yes I mean given that there were
they were just two of us left after the
election to do the nominations if no one
else would like to speak with our move
to the vote so all those in favor
all those against right so that is
carried you off the hook Matthew alright
item number 13 appointment of counselors
the shared revenues partnership
committee I'd like to invite John
Robinson corporate manager Democratic
Services to introduce this item Thank
You chair just to say that in accordance
with the joint Arrangements established
with Bay the District Council and it was
which Borough Council councils asked to
appoint to cabinet members and to
substitutes to serve on the committee
for the current municipal year political
balance rules do not apply to mid suffix
appointees and those nominations have
been tabled thank you I move those
nominations that have been tabled and
could I have a seconder
thank you both of you so well all those
in favor all those against right that's
carried item number 14 counselor
appointments the changes to the
appointments have been tabled are there
any others could I have a proposer Thank
You chair pose thank you please could I
have a seconder I'm sure I'll be happy
to second that eventually yeah just to
say I'm really pleased that you took up
my suggestion of having a member of the
opposition group at least an observer
the LGA and particularly important at
the East region LGA which is somewhere
where I think we need to be made sure
that you know we are a bigger in a
bigger group thank you
so we'll take a break then all those in
favor that's Carrie thank you the date
at the next meeting is Thursday the 25th
of July at 5:30 p.m. and um this meeting
is over